all right Sue hay
Sue hey where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
I grew up by USC by um Adams in Vermont
my parents are Mexican a
Mexican-American Indian
my dad's from Oaxaca and my mom's room
Michoacan
and you grew up in the U.S by USC yeah
and tell me about your parents
um
my dad is an alcoholic and my mom
suffers from domestic violence
yeah saw that growing up
since I was
four till the age I was 15.
then he left the house and he went with
his mistress
and um
that was very traumatic for me but
um it was better for him to leave the
house than for him to keep hitting my
mom
but you weren't getting any abuse right
just your mom I was abused too
um
my damn listed me when I was nine years
old
um
I was growing up so I started developing
and I started getting taught and I saw
my dad see me with the other eyes so I
ran away from home when I was 14.
um paying her own gangsters and
just hanging out
because
um
the people that I was getting abused
from was my real father you know and to
me it was sick so I left my house at
such a young age and I wanted to grow up
real fast
um then I started getting beaten up by
my first husband
and
I left him
and I got with somebody else and we
ended up having um
a little boy and he ended up passing
away and then I had a stroke and I went
paralyzed from half of my arm my leg
and the hospital told me that it was
because of the shock because he died
five feet away from me
and um
he overdosed on
heroin and and
colada pens and alcohol
and
and then
um the government took my kids away
because they said I put them in danger I
did but I rather him passed away in my
house than for him to be passing away in
the street
even though I lost my kids
um and where are your kids now they're
with my brother
he was been raising them ever since
so I thank God for him
they live in Azusa
my daughter she's 16 and my son is 12.
um
yeah um
I am ended up having three more kids
with this other guy
and uh
I felt like um I I wasn't seven months
in a rehab I graduated from Tarzana
Treatment Center then I relapsed again
um I need to enroll this year by the end
of this year to another rehab
what is your drug currently
um heroin and meth
but you're using heroin not fentanyl no
I don't use retinol I use heroin and
meth
um my sister was the first one that got
me started on meth
um
she also gave me my first joint but
she's been 20 years clean and I've been
20 years using and um she regrets it but
um she's only family support I have
right here
um my family moved to a suicide so my
Mom's not around here my sister's the
only one that lives here in LA
so I come in Gold I run the street
um usually on 20 25th and Vermont
um I hang out right there
how do you support yourself
um
um sometimes we sell I sell clothes
shoes
um drugs
um
purses I used to sell men's suits right
here on 7th and Los Angeles for five
years
and I used to live on Fifth in Los
Angeles in the hotel Baltimore
and are you dating men sometimes to make
a buck
no no I don't I've been with my baby's
father for 13 years
he's with me what I do is steal bikes
and sell them
yeah
that's what I do
when you look back at your life what do
you wish you had done differently oh
everything everything
um
I wish I would have started doing drugs
at such a young age I started when I was
10.
smoking marijuana
and then I started doing LSD
I was really in the asset
group at the time when we were like club
kids someone used to go to parties and
everything
we used to go to raids
um sometimes
I I think I had fun but
um it wasn't fun after I had kids you
know because now I have the
responsibility of taking care of them
and whatever I do reflects on them
um
and I'm trying to get back on my feet
I've been coming and going as I please
for eight years
I was in a in a program
but my baby dad he
he can't coming around with drugs and so
on it's like
he kept offering me so one day I just
said yeah just give it to me
and to me it's like
um
like a cigarette and a beer heroin it's
like a cigarette and methods like my
beer you know it's like comes hand in
hand
um what I need to do is change my life
change my life
and have a barrier than I had last year
my family does not know that I do drugs
I mean they have an idea but they
they don't know that I've been doing
heroin for the past
10 years off and on
how does it affect you emotionally
living this lifestyle
it's a burden because I I lost a lot of
friends
just recently
um
three weeks ago one of my friends she
she um died because
her boyfriend beat her up so bad that
she was in a respiratory
machine
um
I lost two of my friends because of
their boyfriends that they killed
what's your biggest fear right now
um
dying thinking thinking for my kids to
think that I'm not trying
you know for me to like oh the
and for my kids to think that I don't
love them
it's my biggest fear
um
but it's so hard with the heroin it's so
hard
they don't tell you that you get sick
you get to be sick if you don't get it
what do you think people outside of this
lifestyle don't understand about people
living on the streets
people they're normies right
um
they don't understand that we use it as
a coping mechanism
like to cope with our lifestyle and with
um everything that's happened to us and
traumatically from childhood to adults
um only people that are into mental
health they're probably understand more
than the regular average person
you know most people would they just
like to judge you know was it just at
one point you discovered that these
drugs numb the pain of what you went
through
as a kid and then eventually you got
hooked on them yeah and then I got a um
figure out how am I gonna do it and not
get sick in front of my sister
I'm in front of my family you know how
am I going to go to a family function if
I can't function you know I will have to
have the drugs on my hand and have
enough
to last me so I could put up with their
stuff
and just to pass through it's not even
to get well anymore it's just I'm just
doing it just to be okay yeah
in the Years you were down here where
did you stay
I stayed in tents cars abandoned houses
um whatever I could stay
friend to friend to friend
yeah
um right now I stay in a car on
oh never mind
and then I go to my sister's house if I
need to take a shower and then I already
paid one of my friends 30 dollars like
it take a shower at his house
yeah because with this weather and
everything
um
I also don't like to look like if I'm
homeless even though I am homeless
you know
the good thing is that I know a lot of
people in the um they're willing to help
me out a lot
is the hardest part of this dealing with
losing your kids
um
and to the to their eyes I put my kids
in danger so because my dad my husband
he he was put on dead as a rival
I feel like they don't even want to deal
with me
but I'm going to try one more time
so I I will be seeing you again next
year
and if you do want to talk to me and
bring um like follow up
that'd be great
that'll be great for me too to see it to
come back with my three kids
look I did it I'd love to see that yeah
so Jay what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
if you fly just get back up
keep on getting back up
living this lifestyle makes you tough
doesn't it
yes it has to
I can't fall I can't keep falling and
falling
I can't keep thinking myself
in that hole and think that I'm never
gonna come out I could come out it's up
to me if I want to change everybody
could tell me to change but it's really
up to me if I want to change
and I'm tired I'm tired
I'm tired of of everything I'm tired of
not having my kids with me
and I see some moms with their kids and
I get so sad
I could only be sad of myself because
nobody's doing me any harm I do it to
myself
all right sujay thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you wish you
the best of luck out here thank you